[Music]
all right
everybody heard the term
everybody's got a price right yeah yeah
yeah what's your price
it depends of what what give me an
example uh what's your price to
i don't know suck a dick sit on my face
five million five million
who's there dude that [ __ ] for pleasure
anybody's egg is it glory hole i don't
care does anybody else ever find out
about it i don't give a [ __ ]
nobody okay not even about me you're
just you're just saying you're going to
suck a dick i'm like do you know what
opportunity i want to do
i think i can find someone for you if
you're really into it you don't do it
for a barber brigade uh twenty percent
off coupon you did not just two percent
off
twenty percent that's gonna be your card
serious answers only how much do you
like suck a dick how much money do you
need everybody can get bought out
i literally just give me some numbers
give me something literally five million
whatever yours is nick will probably pay
somebody to do it yeah i'll pay someone
for a dick i feel like okay you five
million he'll pay you to suck your dick
yeah i got low standards i feel like
your price won that because i feel like
you got asked this question in the past
and you're like 10 grand only but then i
feel like no man was never 10 grand i
think so started out a million i started
at a million
i know my dick sucking quota prices yeah
but i was 27 now i'm older so it went up
yeah it won't work it still got better
inflation yeah
well george clooney
i'm rich as [ __ ] [ __ ] he sucks
some dick no
but he read this one he reveals that he
turned down a 35 million dollar job for
one day's work are you kidding me what
was the job it was a
second dick wait was it really
absolutely michael what the [ __ ] was it
really that was like some like
commercial like airline commercial it
was
foreign deals left and right and [ __ ] so
they're just kind of i feel like he's
not hurting for money and he has so many
opportunities to work if you wanted to
it's kind of like he's also a
billionaire right now right he is
because of his
product yeah yeah yeah which one was it
they're good casamigos
it's quite good so i'm like yeah if
you're a billionaire
35 million
man yeah that's like if someone goes
i'll give you 20 bucks to spend the sign
and i'm like nah i don't need to do it
and people are like oh you saw a title
you son of a [ __ ]
i don't know man 35 million for one
day's work is still pretty even if
you're a billionaire i still got to be
like
worthy to talk about means it's probably
got to be [ __ ] good still right what
if you get you get what if you get these
deals like 10 times a year
then i would love life
if you get these deals 10 times a year
and i mean george clooney's like pretty
old right so like
after the 20th year
this is normal life yeah i don't doubt i
don't doubt a man like him but he's
doing a lot of money yeah yeah but at
what point where because like
out there's a certain point where like
you can't really just money doesn't
[ __ ] matter anymore because like you
could get everything you want whatever
it doesn't [ __ ] matter you're just
like
i don't know i don't need this [ __ ] and
at a certain point like we know some
people were like they're buying failing
businesses to expense money
you know there's a point where it's like
they're at so much money they're not
looking at money as a way to like
improve their life because their life is
already [ __ ] the best they're trying
to play this game
of how not to like
pay too much taxes or how to make you
know some empire [ __ ] they're like
that might be like oh man that's gonna
put me too much across my questions you
see narcos man he has so much money he
was like i'm cold i'm gonna use this
[ __ ] for [ __ ] wood because i don't
have firearms
and he burned the money he just had
nowhere to [ __ ] put the money anymore
they still find it till this day like
farmers will just be like digging and
they're like oh [ __ ] there's five
million buried here that's [ __ ] too
many money yeah damn that's like
investing in shiba you know
how old is george clooney he's like 60 i
think he's 60. is he still fine or what
still fine
yeah that's that's what i'm looking for
he is he's pretty [ __ ] stud muffin
yeah he was born in 61.
i forgot her name but she is like a
very successful is she a politician or
she does something yeah she's she's like
an activist or something yeah or like
women's right actors or something like
that she's gorgeous
she looks like the female version of him
though that's right i mean she's a
sister so casamigos uh was sold
or was acquired in 2017 in a deal up to
a billion dollars so it was initially uh
digo paid 700 million for the brand with
the potential to pay a further 300
million over the following 10 years
depending on the performance of custom
u.s
i want to have that much
like
where i'm like
i don't need 35 million dollars
for a day's work i also would like that
maybe he had a really bad experience at
like [ __ ] delta airlines or whatever
it was and he's like man [ __ ] you guys i
ain't gonna [ __ ] make a commercial
for you guys i remember when your
[ __ ] flight attendant threw soda on
me
[ __ ] delta yeah so the actor
justified his decision by saying that
the country the commercial was uh
associated with was questionable to him
at the time even though it wasn't i do
buy airlines it was an allied nation but
yeah no i think what happened is
he he got something that's supposed to
be delivered right and this fool's at
home but the [ __ ] don't want to
ring the doorbell and he's been waiting
all day and he goes there's a piece of
paper and it says [ __ ] deliver again
tomorrow the next day
the [ __ ] muffler doesn't deliver it
again and then he goes he calls him all
right when are you going to come and he
goes between the hours of 8 a.m and 8
p.m we'll be there and it's the same day
as the goddamn commercials like [ __ ]
these [ __ ] i'ma stand outside
until the package comes
yeah there has to be another reason
whatever happened to you guys 8am to 8pm
dude they always do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude you ever ordered
anything online to tell you it's going
to come in like a [ __ ] 24-hour window
yeah yeah you have to sign for it since
when
if it isn't on amazon prime i don't even
order it anymore i don't care where it's
from if it's not on prime i don't want
it can you make noodles on prime you're
welcome
you can get what what kind of noodles
hey remember when the arcade had to come
here the window was like 7 a.m to like 2
p.m but they come at like 6 59 10. they
did yeah dude why did they do that and
then they like knock on the door once
they bounce unless you [ __ ] know
where they are
it came out like so early in the morning
so anthony was telling me that like you
gotta be here like right at the
beginning of the window you can't show
up at like three hours later and it came
even earlier they know they came at 7 30
but they were about to bounce because of
some like weird stuff that happened how
um like i guess i wasn't on the the
delivery thing or something like that
and they're like you can't take the
order or like i don't know but why are
they so quick to just like let go of
responsibility like nope
because they're busy
so yeah so um george clooney being the
rich [ __ ] that he is he had told
in this article that he said
uh after he had talked with his wife who
was a human rights lawyer that he
married in 2014. they talked about and
decided it's not worth it um oh cause it
was a moral issue like the airlines was
like north korean air or some [ __ ] like
that and he goes i don't know it was an
allied country apparently but yes
something about conflicting things but
anything over 10 million there's no such
thing as morals dude
i know just ask lebron
yeah dude wait wait was that me lebron
his business with china because it's all
about like social justice here in the
states but then he won't speak out about
what's happening in china oh what's he
doing in china what's his business in
china nike he has so much money coming
in from uh nike deals
and then the nba is backed by china too
yeah what are you gonna do stripes over
check so you know what i'm saying
china
i think you can be morally like just
when you're not struggling anymore like
mr clooney's right you'll be like nah i
don't know about north korea airlines so
i'm not going to take that 35 mil but
like any [ __ ] any [ __ ] one of
us peasants will be like 35 mil tell me
where i suck kim jong's dick absolutely
yeah especially if the [ __ ]
blockbuster's still hitting up where the
[ __ ] that video and i don't know where
it is why is my why is my [ __ ] at the
collection agency you know you 10 g's
for [ __ ]
for [ __ ] hot fuzz or something [ __ ]
fun oh [ __ ] it was worth it though good
that was against the good
[ __ ] movie
a little bit on that on that lebron tip
yeah i was like what movies uh it's like
people people can't be 100 perfect would
you forgive a person that had to do like
10 like slightly evil things in order to
have the leverage and the power to do 90
good
uh i want to say yes but at the same
time i think with lebron he just goes so
hard in one direction that it almost
like he acts as though his [ __ ] doesn't
stink like everyone makes mistakes
everybody i like at a certain point no
matter what your morals are like there
are times when you don't follow your
like the [ __ ] that you say and sometimes
you have to do it for like whatever
reason like maybe he needs the money i
don't think he needs money uh maybe he
didn't do the bare minimum though it's
just like
he did he he just went all in china
a lot of people were saying that the uh
elbowing that he did was staged so
people will start talking about that
rather than uh asking him questions
about china oh [ __ ] we should ask him if
he thinks taiwan's a country
hey lebron you think tom was a country
china had john cena apologizing in
mandarin
what happens if lebron goes uh
i don't know like you know if he says
anything that's outside of that then
you're like oh this motherfucker's in
china's pocket man because a lot of this
[ __ ] is like so tied with people's
livelihoods and like careers and all
that stuff right so even in traditional
media a lot of uh news outlets are
sponsored by pfizer and moderna and all
that [ __ ] so they don't want to say
nothing yeah for sure
i mean china is like a huge market right
it's like the next technically biggest
entertainment market after hollywood so
to speak so like that's why like the
rock like will probably do anything to
make sure his movies go into china which
means that he probably won't do anything
to say anything that would insults you
know what i mean the chinese way of life
or anything like that so and john cena
will do anything to be the rock so it's
kind of like
you know
that's true
shots fired at john cena
i feel so bad for john cena because uh
all of this is alleged please don't sue
me john cena um but i know so many
stories about him because he was from
boston really and my boyfriend like grew
up in the same like area same like time
frame where he was growing up and i
heard so many stories about him where i
feel so bad for him give us one juicy
thing um so allegedly his ex-wife used
to uh like [ __ ] around on him all the
time and she'd like this is like him wwe
allegedly and he would have private
investigators follow her to see what
she's doing and she'd yell she like he
knows i'm [ __ ] on him he ain't gonna
do [ __ ] and she like was just spending
up all of his money like [ __ ] around
on him he was quite the simp he was but
like he was in love he was in love with
her and he just like i like him now yeah
yeah like for me john cena is like my my
number one now like ever since i've
heard stories about him he seems like
such like a genuinely nice man he's a
sweet boy he's a sweet man i'm about to
follow him i love john cena imagine
calling john cena boy this is all a
legend i'm so sorry john cena i love you
his ex-wife can get in the streets
though square up
[Music]
you